and we do want to linger for a moment on
the size of those crowds just how long a
line of people were talking about to
give you an idea let's go to the map
this line could stretch along the
ancient river thames past central london
and far beyond the famous tower bridge
roxanna seberry spoke with some of the
people already waiting to view the
queen's coffin as it passes she's at the
lambeth bridge across the river from
westminster hall where the queen will
lie in state roxanna it's been rainy
there overnight but people seem
undeterred good morning
good morning tony this line stretches
back as far as we can see people at the
front arrived two days ago some came
overnight others early this morning they
sat through the rain many people haven't
slept and yet remarkably they're in
pretty high spirits they've been bonding
over this shared experience and many of
them say it's worth lining up or cueing
as they say here to say goodbye to the
only queen they've known
it's a historic moment and i think it's
not going to come around again in my
lifetime i'm not falling asleep i'm not
tired i'm not hungry so i could stay out
another four nights and still wait to
see
the queen
it would still be worth it definitely
to say goodbye
he's number 82 in line out of what's
expected to be hundreds of thousands of
people so he's likely to reach his
destination tonight which is across the
river thames at westminster hall where
the queen will lie in state from this
evening to early monday morning tony
with apologies to our viewers in the uk
it is not a line it is a cue roxanna
sabri for us in london roxanna thank you
very much and of course we're going to
have live coverage of the procession of
the queen's coffin from buckingham
palace to westminster hall as roxanna
just pointed out in a cbs news special
report at 9 00 a.m eastern